l'ex président de la république monsieur
françois mitterrand est mort ce matin à
paris à l'âge de 79 ans des suites de
son cancer
cette image symbole de monsieur françois
mitterrand c'était le 17 mai dernier
quelques minutes avant la passation de
pouvoir avec monsieur jacques chirac
dans les jardins dans le parc de
l'elysée il aimait la nature il avait
tenu à se promener une dernière fois
dans ce parc où il avait vécu pendant 14
ans deux septennats en compagnie de son
médecin il était déjà très marquée par
la maladie qui devait l'emporter
quelques mois plus tard monsieur
françois mitterrand est donc décédé ce
matin à 8h30 à paris
madame monsieur bonsoir cette édition
spéciale du journal est bien entendu
consacrer entièrement à la disparition
de l'ancien président de la république
monsieur françois mitterrand reportages
témoignages en direct pendant plus d'une
heure suivi tout à l'heure d'une france
en direct qui retracera l'ensemble de la
carrière des cinquante années de vie
politique du chef de l'état qui a dit y
ait disparu ce matin
mais avant les personnalités avant les
reportages avant le monde politique que
nous voulons vous faire entendre les
réactions de français qui ce matin on a
pris dans la rue à leur travail
la disparition de l'ancien chef de
l'état écoutons les
paris à 11h ce matin la nouvelle vient à
peine de tomber sur mitterrand vient de
décéder ce matin françois mitterrand
vient de décéder ce matin
une blague ou quoi non non c'est pas
nouvelle ce matin à dakar
décédé d'un cancer de la prostate oui
bien sûr que ça exige été saluée voilà
voilà
c'est vrai que ça faisait un moment il
en avait parlé un que vous savez que ça
n'avait pas très bien la voilà la
rondeur sont maintenant qu'il est décidé
à 8 heures
écoutez là franchement
je sais pas quoi dire
je pensais que un petit peu il est
éternel
oui les heures passent l'émotion laisse
peu à peu alors la place à la réplique
si vous n'êtes pas je crois l'un des
plus grands politiques que nous n'ayons
jamais eue c'était un pour certains un
machiavel pour d'autres un fin stratège
je crois que la droite ne peut tirer les
leçons du parcours politique de françois
mitterrand qui était exceptionnel il ya
eu ses deux septennats et qui ont marqué
une génération de jeunes génération
mitterrand comme on a dit et c'est
quelqu'un qui au point de vue politique
a su je dirais travailler dans la dans
la longévité
15 heures c'est l'affluence autour des
kiosques la mort de françois mitterrand
fait la une des journaux du soir devant
le journal pour un ancien morts
une image qui reste le chat
bah c'est l'homme dean qui marche tout
droit sur le porge elysées en partant de
ses deux septennats et
gray la douleur de la maladie et tout ce
que vous pouvez dire sur la politique
qu'il a menée rester très droit et le
regard fuyant du tout je pense surtout
que l'essentiel est de pur style ans
dans ces cas-là et de prier moi je suis
une croyante je crois que les dés
là on peut le plus l'aider c'est
vraiment de le porter dans la prière de
prier pour que son âme fille céline b
dans un peu moins d'une minute
maintenant le chef de l'état monsieur
chirac prononcera en direct de l'elysée
une allocution à la suite du décès de
monsieur françois mitterrand mais tout
de suite nous allons nous rendre dans le
7e arrondissement de paris nous
rejoignons benoît duquesne là où est
mort ce matin monsieur françois
mitterrand où les français ne cessent de
défiler maintenant c'est vrai qu'ici
toute la journée on a assisté à un
défilé de personnalités d'amis d'un team
de françois mitterrand et puis aussi à
un défilé de d'anonymes qui venait
témoigner aussi de leurs seins de leur
amitié mais d'abord j'aurais montrait
cette image celle de l'épousé du chef de
l'état de madame mitterrand qui a quitté
il y a à peine une heure
ces bureaux paris voilà donc notre père
en quittant l'immeuble où est mort ce
matin monsieur mitterrand est tout de
suite l'allocution du président de
république monsieur jacques chirac
mes chers compatriotes le président
françois mitterrand est mort ce matin
les français ont appris avec émotion la
disparition de celui qui les a guidés
pendant 14 ans je voudrais saluer la
mémoire de l'homme d'état mais aussi
rendre hommage à l'homme dans sa
richesse et sa complexité
françois mitterrand c'est une heure
grands lecteurs amoureux des beaux
livres
l'écriture était pour lui une
respiration naturelle sa langue
classique fut toujours la traductrice
fidèles et sensible de sa pensée
françois mitterrand c'est une volonté
volonté de servir certains idéaux la
solidarité et la justice sociale le
message humaniste dont notre pays est
porteur et qui s'enracine au plus
profond de nos traditions l'europe une
europe dans laquelle la france
réconciliée avec l'allemagne et
travaillant avec elle occuperait une
place de premier rang mais aussi une
façon de vivre notre démocratie une
démocratie moderne apaisées grâce
notamment à l' alternance maîtrisée qui
a montré que le changement de majorité
ne signifiait pas crise politique et nos
institutions en ont été renforcées en
politique
françois mitterrand fut d'abord
profondément respectueux de la personne
humaine et c'est pourquoi il décida
d'abolir la peine de marc respecte
aussi des droits de l'homme il ne cessa
d'intervenir partout où ils étaient
bafoués ces choix était clair et il les
a toujours fait au nom de l'idée qu'il
se faisait de la france
mais françois mitterrand c'est d'abord
et avant tout je crois une vie certaines
existence sont paisibles et égrène des
jours semblables parsemaient
d'inconvénients ou d'événements privés
le président mitterrand contraire donne
le sentiment d'avoir déborder sa propre
vie il a épousé son siècle plus de 50
ans ac au coeur de l'arène politique au
coeur des choses en train de s'accomplir
la guerre la résistance
les mandats électoraux les ministères
dont tout jeune il assume la charge
la longue période ensuite où il sera
d'une des figures majeures de
l'opposition avec détermination
opiniâtreté pugnacité ses deux
septennats
enfin où il prendra toute sa dimension
imprimant sa marque son style à la
france des années 80
mais françois mitterrand n'est pas
réductible à son parcours s'il démarre
dès sa vie c'est parce qu'il avait la
passion de la vie passion qui
nourrissait et permettez son propre
dialogue avec la mort la vie sous toutes
ses formes la vie dans ces heures
sombres et ses heures glorieuses la vie
du terroir la vie de nos campagnes
cette france rurale qu'il a tant aimée
presque charnellement il connaissait
notre pays jusque dans ces villages est
partout il avait une relation un ami car
il avait la passion de l'amitié la
fidélité que l'on doit à ses amis était
pour lui un dogme qui l'emporté sur
toute autre
il suscite en retour des fidélités
profonde au travers des années des
épreuves ma situation est singulière car
j'ai été l'adversaire du président
françois mitterrand
mais j'ai été aussi son premier ministre
et je suis aujourd'hui son successeur
tout cela tisse un lien particulier où
il entre du respect pour l'homme d'étain
et de l'admiration pour l'homme privé
qui s'est battu contre la maladie avec
un courage remarquable la toise entend
quelque sorte qu'ils ne cessant de
remporter des victoires contre elle de
cette relation avec lui qu'on ce
contraste est plus ancienne je retiens
la force du courage quand il est soutenu
par une volonté la nécessité de replacer
l'homme au coeur de tout projet le poids
aussi de l'expérience
seul compte finalement ce que l'on est
dans sa vérité est ce que l'on peut
faire pour la france en ce soir de deuil
pour notre pays
s'adresse à madame mitterrand et à sa
famille
le témoignage de mon respect et de ma
sympathie à leurs françois mitterrand
entre dans l'histoire
je souhaite que nous méditions son
message
après cette allocution en direct du
président la république monsieur jacques
chirac à la mémoire de monsieur françois
mitterrand j'ajouterai que le brillant à
public a décidé que je dis en janvier
serait décrété journée de deuil national
en france ce même jeudi 11 janvier
monsieur françois mitterrand sera
enterré à jarnac sa ville natale là où
il est né le 26 octobre 1916 enterrement
qui aura lieu dans l'intimité
nous retournons maintenant à l'actualité
de ce soir qui sont les suit donc du
décès de la disparition de monsieur
françois mitterrand une vision avant
d'entendre le chef de l'état madame
danielle mitterrand qui s'est trouvé
toute la journée au cours autour de la
dépouille mortelle de son mari a quitté
ce soir l'immeuble de l'avenue du play
pour regagner son domicile
on la voit ici il ya quelques instants
au sortir de l'immeuble où repose le
corps de l'ancien chef de l'état
nous rejoignons maintenant toujours
devant cet immeuble du 7e arrondissement
benoît duquesne avec qui nous étions en
conversation juste avant l'intervention
monsieur jacques chirac benoît oui tout
à fait je voulais justement avant de
revenir aux personnalités qui sont venus
ici toute cette journée a commencé par
jacques chirac qui est donc venu
surveiller sur la dépouille de me
françois mitterrand avant d'annoncer
officiellement son décès pour donner la
parole un petit peu à une ou deux
personnes qui depuis ce matin où depuis
1h ou 2h ou 3h sont ici simplement
attendre par signe d'amitié et dommages
à l'ancien chef de l'état mme loiselle
vous avez je crois à 22 22 ans ça
représente pour quoi pour vous le décès
de françois mitterrand mais en fait j'ai
l'impression que c'est un peu une partie
de mon enfance qui part avec lui ce
parce que j'avais 8 ans les gens son
élection et c'est une soirée qui m'a
marqué et c'est pour moi j'ai connu que
françois mitterrand c'était le président
le président de
2 c'est pas de beaucoup des sports et le
président moi je connais c'est vrai que
j'étais jeune avant et c'est là c'est
cela à partir de ce moment là j'ai
commencé un peu à prendre conscience de
de la politique et c'est je suis ému et
vous aussi vous aussi vous êtes vous dit
tout à l'heure que c'était quelque chose
pour vous ce départ du de lancieux
d'état oui en fait moi en 88 j'avais
voté pour lui j'avais mis beaucoup
d'espérance je croyais beaucoup ans
l'homme est aujourd'hui c'est une je
dirais si une part de nous-mêmes du
tiret de la part de tous les français
qui qui s'en va c'est un 1 2 qui marge
du rassemblement qui marquera l'histoire
alors je vous le disais tout à l'heure
on a eu beaucoup de personnalités qui
sont passés ici toute la journée
monsieur chirac en début de journée
monsieur yasser arafat qui se trouvait à
paris et qui a donc tenu à venir saluer
la dépouille du de l'ancien chef de
l'état monsieur arafat
vous le savez avaient été reçus et
françois mitterrand avait été le premier
chef d'état à recevoir yasser arafat à
l'elysée sans oublier le fameux discours
à la knesset où il est allé il était
allé parler au nom des palestiniens ou
en tout cas défendre la cause et pasinya
devant la knesset à jérusalem sur le
défilé de toutes ces personnalités
aujourd'hui aussi bien monsieur balladur
que monsieur juppé que monsieur valéry
giscard d'estaing que les proches les
intimes
les personnalités du parti socialiste
vous propose de voir en images ce qu'a
été cette journée avec le reportage
d'anne isr amiens
toute la journée il est resté sur le pas
de la porte pierre tourlier le chauffeur
de françois mitterrand à regarder passer
les anonymes et a accueilli les
personnalités
c'est lui qui ce matin a demandé aux
militants a couru de revenir plus tard
pour laisser place aux intime à la
famille
robert mitterrand le frère roger hanin
le beau-frère muré dans le silence et
dans le cercle des intimes georges
kiejman la burqa l'ami roland dumas le
confident et jack lang rester un très
long moment
enfin michel charasse ou encore andré
roussel homme de presse qui comme tous
les autres n'a rien voulu dire dans le
périmètre bouclé autour du 9 rue
frédéric le play sont arrivés ensuite
nous les intimes mais les fidèles les
ténors du socialiste robert badinter
pierre joxe laurent fabius tous ceux à
qui françois mitterrand avait offert la
victoire en 81 l'actuelle première
secrétaire du ps et les militants pour
quelques mots il a voulu défendre la
liberté de la france
je crois que c'est ce message à la fois
personnel humain qui indique aussi sa
relation à la mort puisqu'il s'est battu
contre la mort défendu sa propre liberté
contre la maladie
je crois que c'est ce message qui
laissera moi j'ai notamment en mémoire
président de la république
rencontrant une place d'enfant dans une
école de belleville il y a quelques
années
hélas une majorité d'enfants d'immigrés
et sachant de leur donner le sentiment
qu'ils étaient pour lui des enfants de
la france parmi les autres pour un
dernier adieu après les compagnons de
route
les adversaires politiques sont venus le
foyer ministre alain juppé edouard
balladur mais aussi robert hue
les communistes avec il avait gouverné
c'est un homme quels que soient les
différences les aléas les combats qui
ont été menées ils font partie de
l'histoire
c'est un homme exceptionnel
autre culture un talent très élevé
une grande détermination pierre tourlier
s'efface valéry giscard d'estaing avait
été battu par françois mitterrand ce
soir il est là hommage aussi de nicole
notât de la cfdt est arrivé de lille en
début de soirée pierre mauroy vers 19h
soutenu danielle mitterrand dont les
façons gentiment guidée à quitter le 9
février avec le play pour recueillir les
témoignages les messages d'amitié pierre
tourlier lui est resté fidèle au club
pierre tu oublies était depuis de très
nombreuses années
le chauffeur de l'ancien président de
l'as public mort ce matin nous montrions
tout à l'heure en commençant ce journal
des images de monsieur françois
mitterrand dans les jardins de l'elysée
c'était le 17 mai dernier quelques
minutes avant qu'il ne passe le pouvoir
à jacques chirac qui venait d'être élu
qu'a fait le président de la république
l'ancien président de l'apic monsieur
mitterrand pendant ces sept mois et qui
ont connu leur fin ce matin avec sa
disparition aux alentours de 8h30
on savait déjà que depuis plus d'un an
le président de la république monsieur
françois mitterrand était déjà très
touchés par le cancer qui devait
l'emporter
comment at il vécu ces sept derniers
mois de sa vie
le reportage de françoise david
m
c'était le jour françois mitterrand
avait abandonné son costume de chef de
l'état il n'avait pas encore quitté ses
habits d'homme public dernier ben
cousins président socialiste au soir de
la passation de pouvoir
abane foule sentimentale un hommage
rendu par le peuple de gauche
ise guerre finir
maîtres mots
ce printemps là fut celui du temps
retrouvé
flânerie dans paris en compagnie d'amis
proches et de passants amicaux visite
aux bouquinistes les sûrs que je n'ai
pas lu sont plus nombreux que ce que
j'ai lu disent-ils 49 ans d'un même
voyage la même pèlerinage qui le conduit
chaque dimanche de pentecôte à la roche
de solutré dans ce morvan qu'il aime
tant les premiers compagnons de cette
rituel ascension ne sont plus là
d'autres amis l'attendent et joe si
fidèle au rendez vous
françois mitterrand n'a pas voulu céder
devant la maladie bien sûr l'escapade
sur la plus difficile et plus courte
qu'à l'accoutumée elle s'arrêtera ni
quand mais le pique nique sera tout de
même joué un tour dans un bureau de vote
à château chinon pour les élections
municipales de juin 95 et françois
mitterrand s'offrent de longues vacances
le gers l'auvergne l'atce venir avant de
retrouver bel ce coin de bretagne était
devenu comme un nouveau port d'attache
l'ancien président avait été séduit par
la beauté de la côte sauvage
ils venaient s'y reposer en famille ils
prendre son temps temps de lire et de
relire temps de se promener temps de
penser et de méditer temps de sacrifier
au rituel des crêpes et des fruits de
mer
sur l'album de photos de cet été là il y
avait un homme entouré des siens enfants
et petits enfants amis très proches et
fidèles l'image d'un homme qui en
quittant l'elysée avait un peu reconquis
la liberté
lorsqu'un homme politique devient
président de la république chef de
l'état il ya comme cela des lieux
anonymes qui deviennent très vite sellem
ce fut le cas de la rue de bièvre à
paris le long des quais de la seine là
où le président de la république
monsieur françois mitterrand possédait
une maison particulière nous rejoignons
là bas j'ai vite humbert oui tout près
du 22 rue de bièvre exactement l'adresse
parisienne de françois mitterrand ou ce
soir peu après 19h15 venant donc du
septième arrondissement où repose le
président m'a l'ancien président madame
danielle mitterrand s'est rendue elle se
trouve toujours à son domicile de la rue
de bière actuellement il faut savoir que
l'épousé de l'ancien chef de l'état
réside toujours dans cette maison
achetée par le couple il ya maintenant
quelques 25 ans françois mitterrand lui
on sait on l'a dit avait élu domicile
dans le 7e arrondissement
ce qui ne l'empêché pas de garder
quelques habitudes ici dans le 5ème au
coeur de ce quartier latin il émet
notamment flâner près des quais de seine
ou sur le boulevard saint germain où
l'on trouve de nombreux bouquinistes de
nombreux libraires
on connaissait la passion de françois
mitterrand pour la littérature
en tout cas depuis ce matin ce périmètre
de la rue de bièvre est bouclée par un
imposant dispositif policier
on ne passe pas dans la rue de bière pas
même à pied et puis ici aussi de
nombreux parisiens viennent saluer la
mémoire de l'ancien président ils
viennent tous une rose à la main ce soir
encore des roses qu'ils remettent aux
policiers en faction près de la rue qui
se charge ensuite de les déposer devant
le domicile de la famille mitterrand il
ya ce soir beaucoup de fleurs devant le
22 rue de bièvre dans ce quartier où
l'ancien chef de l'état avait longtemps
vécu
merci j'ai vite imbert avant de
poursuivre cette édition spéciale avec
notamment les invités qui m'ont joint
comme madame simone veil monsieur
jacques delors monsieur pierre joxe et
monsieur françois léotard il va nous
falloir maintenant résumé l'avis de
monsieur françois mitterrand cinquante
années de vie politique monsieur
mitterrand est mort à l'âge de 79 ans il
était né le 26 octobre 1916 à jarnac pas
facile de résumer une vie aussi plein
comme nous l'a présenté tout à l'heure
le président jacques chirac dans son
allocution
francis mercure rhône
et
cinquième enfant d'un milieu de droite
petits bourgeois et catholiques de
charente françois mitterrand happé par
la guerre se retrouve prisonnier en
allemagne
c'est là qu'il découvre vraiment tout à
la fois la condition humaine et le prix
des amitiés il s'évade à trois reprises
choisit d'abord vichy puis rejoint la
résistance le nom de mort l'an où il
rencontre daniel qu'il épouse en 44 en
même temps que la politique il entre au
gouvernement de la libération
malgré sa mésentente avec 2go
c'est ainsi que j'ai pris part au
premier gouvernement de la france
libérée sous la présidence du général de
gaulle là j'ai pris de grandes leçons de
gaulle parti françois mitterrand sera
l'un des piliers la quatrième république
on soit min il est à l'intérieur quand
débute la guerre d'algérie qui sonnera
le glas du régime des baux leurs revenus
ils entrent résolument dans l'opposition
octobre 59 la sphère de l'observatoire
accusé d'avoir simulé un attentat contre
lui son immunité parlementaire élevé
mais son acharnement contre de gaulle
remettent en selle il dénonce surtout
d'état permanent se retrouve en 65
candidat de toute la gauche à la
présidentielle et mais de gaulle en
ballottage mai 68 françois mitterrand
croit son heure venue
mais ta proposition du gouvernement
provisoire rejetée et pinet 71
il fonde le ps sur les décombres de la
et sefyu
voilà pour l'instrument de conquête du
pouvoir pour la stratégie
ce sera l'union de la gauche la
signature avec les communistes du
programme commun de gouvernement
puis je veux te voir comme moi je suis
socialiste membre du parti socialiste
tous les socialistes sont là je ne suis
pas 74 mitterrand se mesure à giscard la
gauche unie ne suffit pas pour
l'emporter il manque 400 mille voix mais
le score démontre que le succès n'est
pas une chimère
pourtant les communistes qui se sentent
pris en otages font tout court on est au
sein du ps un rival michel rocard lui
dispute la candidature à la
présidentielle mais mitterrand tient bon
françois mitterrand était élu président
sa victoire est d'abord celle des forces
de la jeunesse des forces du travail
nationalisation décentralisation
abolition de la peine de mort 39 eur
cinquième semaine de congés ministre
communiste après l'état de grâce et la
crise le temps de la rigueur des
restructurations de la dévaluation des
manifestations les partisans de l'école
libre tiennent la rue la guerre scolaire
emporte pierre mauroy au profit de
laurent fabius la sphère greenpeace fini
entamé la confiance françois mitterrand
s'apprête à cohabiter
jacques chirac essuie les plâtres de son
face à face avec le président qui refuse
de signer les ordonnances de
privatisation
la jeunesse est dans la rue et la mort
d'un étudiant fait avorter les réformes
universitaires caldoches contre canach
en nouvelle calédonie la crise et
sanglante
et puis la france subit durement les
effets du terrorisme international
contre les factieuses et les bandes
françois mitterrand brega second
septennat
c'est l'ouverture
michel rocard revenu en grâce devient
premier ministre
les accords matignon ramène la paix en
nouvelle calédonie surgit le temps des
affaires fait signer ces initiés urba et
les fausses factures du ps michel rocard
doit fait passer devant edith cresson
dans la fougue précipite l'arrivée à
matignon de pierre bérégovoy 70,92 la
maladie françois mitterrand est opérée
d'un cancer de la prostate pense que
c'est un combat honorable à mener contre
oman
le référendum sur l'europe divise la
france 2 le oui l'emportent de justesse
les législatives perdues
c'est la deuxième cohabitation cette
fois avec edouard balladur le suicide de
pierre bérégovoy fige le pays et la
boursede stupeur juillet 94 me cancer du
président nécessite une seconde
intervention
attaqué sur son passé à vichy et ses
relations avec rené bousquet ont
sommités un fait front on était aussi
attaqué est-ce que lui voyez tout ce
qu'on dit de moi un qui me ferait ans
en d'autres temps où bondir des colères
ou souffrir vraiment à un chagrin
immense
ce n'est pas parce que j'ai la
conscience anti
parvenu au terme de son mandat après
avoir transmis le pouvoir à son
successeur jacques chirac au moment des
adieux
françois mitterrand choisi de recevoir
l'hommage des socialistes
je pense qu'il ya des millions de
français qui ne gardent le souvenir très
fort ce que nous avons vécu ensemble
j'ai pris des risques
j'assume je me sens très en paix avec
moi même
non seulement les derniers mois de la
vie de monsieur françois mitterrand
furent particulièrement marquée par la
maladie qui le tenaillait ce cancer mais
déjà sa dernière année au pouvoir avait
été marqué par cette maladie monsieur
mitterrand n'avait jamais rien caché de
sa santé dès le début de son premier
septennat d'ailleurs et ensuite
lorsqu'il fut opéré à plusieurs reprises
pour repousser les assauts du cancer il
t'a à faire des déclarations publiques
sur son état de santé sa capacité à
continuer à gouverner quel était le
malade françois mitterrand qui se
battaient qui luttaient pour rester en
vie
jean daniel flaysakier en septembre 1992
on apprend que françois mitterrand a été
opéré à l'hôpital cochin intervention
s'est déroulée dans le service du
professeur bernard debré elle a été
réalisée par le professeur a dit steg
pour la première fois on évoque
officiellement le diagnostic
il s'agit d'un cancer de la prostate au
fond comme vous le voulez face je pense
que c'est un combat honorable à mener
contre soi même
c'est un homme qui avait certainement la
volonté non seulement de combattre sa
souffrance mais aussi de vivre comme
vous et c'est ce qui lui a permit
vraisemblement de vivre plus longtemps
mais la maladie progresser traitement
échoue en juillet 1994 il faudrait
opérer le président on lui pose alors
deux sombres dans les uretères à peine
deux mois après son intervention très
fatigué il parle avec pudeur de sa
maladie et de la douleur
ça devrait durer encore quelques temps
quand même c'est à dire non pas de
pronostic qu'il puisse se justifier
est ce que vous savez combien de temps
il vous restait vive je suis en
situation de combat
et quand j'ai livré un combat je me mets
aussi d'un état d'esprit et de celui qui
gagnera il gagne ou moins une manche de
ce combat puisqu'il ira au terme de son
deuxième mandat
grâce à l'aide d'un spécialiste de la
douleur et d'un urologue qui
l'accompagneront jusqu'au terme de sa
vie on a beaucoup posé la question de
savoir si une fois la présidence à un
public quitter sa maladie il aurait
dominé plus que lorsqu'il était en
activité
je n'en suis pas sûre qu'il a continué
très actif il le disait il s'était
préparé tout à fait à sept changements
de vie et je ne pense pas que ça a
échoué
françois mitterrand a surpris le monde
médical en résistant si longtemps au mal
qui le ronge et malgré des métastases
osseuses
il a réussi à se promener à escalader la
roche de solutré la force de son esprit
à semble-t-il pour un temps pu juguler
la progression des cellules cancéreuses
c'est donc à jarnac en charente là où il
était né le 26 octobre 1916 que jeudi
prochain monsieur françois mitterrand
sera inhumé dans la plus stricte
intimité jarnac
c'est donc la ville de naissance de
l'ancien chef de l'état qui est mort ce
matin à jarnac le père de françois
mitterrand était le chef de gare de la
ville
hommage anonyme cet après midi devant le
futur tombeau de françois mitterrand mon
père ma mère et
on perd en même temps la tolérance son
père une partie de quatre opérateurs ont
perdu l'espoir on perd plein de choses
françois mitterrand a choisi de
retrouver sa terre natale de charente
dans le petit cimetière de jarnac
il reposera aux côtés de joseph et
yvonne mitterrand ses parents il avait
ses habitudes y retourner chez le
libraire est retourné à l'église sourd
et faire son petit tour et l'intérêt
pour lui à jarnac c'est que les gens le
saluer comme ç'avait été le voisin
ils étaient ni insulter ni adoré c'était
intéressant pour lui je pense c'est au
22 de la rue abel guy à la vinaigrerie
comme on dit ici que françois mitterrand
avait vu le jour le 26 octobre 1916
jusqu'à l'âge de 18 ans il vivra en
charente et fréquentera l'école de la
ville notre directrice à l'école
sainte-marie manager de gand avait dit
de lui ce garçon sera un jour où
président de la république ou évêques
c'était une personnalité emile bilhau le
libraire de jarnac très lié avec la
famille mitterrand le fauteuil du
président le fauteuil où il aimait
s'asseoir quand et de rentrer en suivant
le président venait se ressourcer dans
cette boutique
l'occasion d'échanger des idées mais
bien est dans la cognito la haie et
penser à travers des rues s'attarder sur
le pont de jarnac pour voir là bas du
côté disons des grand'maisons il avait
ses points peut gérer sans doute à
jarnac
mais on chantait quelqu'un d'attaché
viscéralement à jarnac b
aujourd'hui les 5000 habitants de jarnac
semble avoir pris l'eau deuil je suis un
peu surpris mais enfin ça ne pardonne
pas cette maladie la sommerau les tris
aujourd'hui aux bruits comme toi peut
pas tout le monde
rapidement on enlève les dernières
décorations de noël jeudi sur les rives
de la charente que françois mitterrand
apprécié tant il faudra être prêt pour
l'adieu à l'enfant du pays avant de
continuer un détour par l'elysée où nous
retrouvons véronique sainte olive pour
nous parler des cérémonies qui sont
organisées ce jeudi 11 janvier le jour
même donc où monsieur françois
mitterrand sera inhumé dans sa ville de
jarnac que nous voulons voir à l'instant
véronique et bien oui andré rousselet
l'un des amis les plus proches de
françois mitterrand et son exécuteur
testamentaire a été reçu cet après midi
à l'elysée par par jacques chirac
pendant plus d'une heure et les deux
hommes ont mis au point ensemble les
modalités des funérailles tels que
l'ancien président la république
françois mitterrand les avait lui-même
souhaité jeudi 11 août prochain sera
donc décrété journée de deuil national
les drapeaux seront mis en berne sur
tous les bâtiments officiels
instructions ont été données au ministre
pour faire respecter un moment de
recueillement dans toutes les
administrations les écoles et les
services publics la dépouille mortelle
de l'ancien président de la république
sera donc transféré jeudi matin par
avion militaire dans la matinée à jarnac
où les honneurs militaires lui seront
rendus
parallèlement aux obsèques françois
mitterrand a lui même voulu se dérouler
dans la plus stricte intimité
parallèlement à ces obsèques familiale
un service solennelle sera rendu dans la
cathédrale de notre dame de paris
exactement la même heure à 11 heures
jeudi matin et à l'issue de cette messe
solennelle le président jacques chirac
recevra ici à l'elysée les chefs d'état
de gouvernement et de délégations qui
auront assisté à la cérémonie
merci véronique pour ces précisions le
moment est venu de nous entretenir avec
nos invités en commençant par celui qui
est en direct avec nous et qui est
maintenant monsieur jospin
le successeur de françois mitterrand à
la tête du parti socialiste vous voilà à
la tête d'ing
lourd héritage oui je suis dans un
bureau où françois mitterrand a vécu
pensé travailler avant de devenir
président de la république et je suis
effectivement à la tête d'un parti qui
l'art fondé en 1971 et qui à travers un
parcours qui peut apparaître fulgurant
10 ans 71 80 mais qui a été fait de
mouvements d'avancé de reflux a conduit
finalement non seulement les socialistes
mais la gauche au pouvoir où elle
n'avait pas été depuis longtemps et donc
c'est une
c'est un sentiment de tristesse
c'est en même temps un afflux de
souvenirs que nous avons les uns et les
autres tous les socialistes qui savent
cette nouvelle aujourd'hui est celui que
je suis à la tête de ce parti
à votre avis monsieur jospin quelle est
la part la plus importante de l'héritage
monsieur françois mitterrand quelle est
la ligne sur laquelle vous n'allez pas
déroger qui était déjà la sienne
je suis pas sûr que j'ai envie
d'exprimer les choses en termes purement
politique parce que je pense que
françois mitterrand était pleinement un
politique
il avait une passion pour la vie
publique il considérait la vie publique
la politique comme un art et en même
temps c'était un homme qui était
profondément humain c'est-à-dire qu'il
aimait la vie
il aimait la culture il aime l amitié
c'est à dire que c'est un homme qui ne
pouvaient pas se réduire à la dimension
politique et je crois que c'est
d'ailleurs pourquoi les françaises et
les français elle l'aimait et l'admirais
parce qu'il était autre chose qu'un
homme politique ou bien politiciens g20
jusqu'à un héritage
oui l'héritage néanmoins je crois que
c'est la volonté de ne pas opposer les
nécessités de la bataille économique et
la justice sociale l'esprit de
fraternité et de partage
l'héritage c'est je crois aussi une
grande politique une grande volonté
européenne
on entrevoit quelques jours monsieur c
oui oui non je dis la rente adossée vous
en prie terminés ou terminés pardon
excusons je voulais dire simplement
l'héritage c'est un attachement profond
à la france et en même temps la volonté
que cette france ne soit pas fermée mais
s'ouvre
les réalités du monde voilà pour moi
l'essentiel bien alors on trouvera tout
à l'heure monsieur jospin dans la france
en direct cela dit tout de même
peut-être un mot encore monsieur jospin
sûr si vous deviez retenir quelque chose
une chose de double septennat de
monsieur françois mitterrand ou de
l'ensemble de sa vie politique ce serait
quoi
je dirais la décentralisation c'est à
dire la fin du du vieux centralisme
français je dirais les grandes réformes
de justice sociale la volonté et une
maîtrise de l'économie et c'est je pense
ces messages d'une société française
plus équilibrée qui à la fois s'affirmer
s'ouvre sur les autres que ces messages
qu'il faut prolonger par notre action
publique les uns et les autres et puis
aussi c'est le souvenir d'un homme qui a
été pour moi un peu un mètre et qui est
aussi dans dans dans profondément en moi
un ami avec qui j'ai j'ai aimé partager
échanger et ça je crois que de nombreux
socialistes l'ont fait et ce qu'ils
n'ont pas pu le faire parmi d'autres
français ont eu envie de le faire et à
travers cela on sentit françois
mitterrand comme proche d'eux merci
monsieur jospin deuxième invité lui
aussi à l'extérieur avant de converser
avec ceux qui sont sur notre plateau
monsieur françois dalle monsieur dalle
bonsoir bonsoir monsieur dalle vous vous
êtes plutôt l'ami n'ont pas d'enfant
semé de jeunesse de françois mitterrand
c'est le copain d'études le copain des
années de guerre que dont nous voulons
parler avec vous quel souvenir en gardez
vous écoutez j'ai des souvenirs de
partage des études avec françois
mitterrand nous allions à la faculté
tous les jours ensemble
mitterrand était un homme calme pondéré
il chercher la vérité
à un moment donné où la france était
assez bouleversé entre 36 et 39 le
milieu étudiant était inquiet concernant
son avenir il y avait beaucoup de
chômeurs
huit cent mille chômeurs la france était
pauvre et nous savions nous nous
demandions ce que nous allions devenir
surtout à lorsque nous parlions
politique extérieure nous voyons monter
l'hyper isme donc nous étions des gens
qui est embêtant d'être serein n'étions
pas angoissé parce que nous avions la
pression et surtout lui avait
l'impression que de toute façon il
dirigerait sa vie dans un sens et
d'utilité l'efficacité justement
monsieur dalle mitterrand qui a 20 ans
avant la guerre est déjà un homme
convaincu qu'il va faire de la politique
il va avoir un grand destin national ou
bien alors il pense à ces études
d'avocat ou à autre chose un an plus tôt
mais t'es rock qui a fait des études de
droit n'avait jamais eu la tornade
jamila temps n'avait jamais eu
l'intention de devenir avocat ou notaire
ou ou d'avoir une carrière juridique
nuitées on savait très bien
en tout cas il le dit le disaient ils me
le disent à moi que sa vocation était
d'aller dans le sens de la politique
mais vous savez à 18 ans ou à 19 ans
nous en parlions il me disait comment
pourrais je peux ni redevenir député
lorsqu'on est un enfant qu'il ya la
province à paris qu'on n'a pas de
relation mais c'était quand même déjà
ses objectifs
ils voulaient s'insérer dans la
politique je vous remercie monsieur
dalle parmi les invités de notre journal
bien entendu des adversaires politiques
aussi de monsieur françois mitterrand
madame simone veil vous avez été
ministre pendant la cohabitation vous
êtes une adversaire politique de
monsieur françois mitterrand mais vous
l'avez pratiqué quel souvenir en
gardez-vous comment jugez-vous l'homme
et l'homme politique
oui je crois que sur l'homme jacques
chirac a dit enfin le président de la
république a dit a fait un portrait
admirable je crois qu'il n'y a rien à
ajouter simplement comme justement je
les ai connus ou pendant la cohabitation
j'étais même ses côtés pendant le
conseil des ministres d'hier et que
j'admire et d'avoir son courage son
courage physique extraordinaire
vous voyez il ne cachait pas par moments
qu'il souffrait de souffrait beaucoup
mais il se conduisaient le conseil des
ministres avec une maîtrise
extraordinaire et une égalité d'humeur
qui devait être certainement très très
difficile a dominé et puis malgré ses
souffrances
malgré cette maladie guy l'atteignait
grassement ses interventions au cours du
conseil notamment ce qu'ils vont cerne
la politique internationale qui était
toujours passionnantes très intéressante
de vision originale certains autour de
la table les approuvaient d'autres moins
mais qui était quelque chose de toujours
intéressant avec une vision prospective
qui était celle d'un homme d'état tréso
toujours passionné d affaires des
affaires interdite la veille
cette soirée n'est pas le lieu de
polémiques mais tous même les dernières
années les derniers mois de monsieur
françois mitterrand a été marquée par un
certain nombre de révélations sur ses
relations avec des responsables du
gouvernement de vichy de vichy comme
monsieur bousquet avec qui il avait
remis conserver une amitié comment vous
simone veil avez-vous ressenti ces
révélations françois mitterrand était un
homme complexe il n'y a pas seulement
ces révélations tout son passé politique
et un pc politique si on pense françois
dalle évoqué la période où il était
jeune homme et on sait très bien qu'à
l'époque politiquement c'était il fait
plutôt à droite dû patienter maurrassien
ou pas mais en tout cas est inspiré par
morath
même si en même temps sa vie a été
marquée par un catholicisme social qui
est aussi une très grande importance
dans ses racines donc je crois que tout
le personnage était un personnage à la
fois très riche et en même temps contenu
est peut-être de cette richesse d'une
grande complexité
alors on a parlé
on parle quelques fois la continuité ou
je crois que c'est un des témoins qu'on
a entendu qui a parlé de longévité
moi je voudrais parler de ce qui est là
à la longévité on le sait a beaucoup
marqué la france et on voit bien elle a
occupé il soir de france pendant mon
depuis des décennies pour partie en tout
cas est en tout cas pendant les deux
septennats mais jouait déjà on voit
l'importance à moi ce que je voudrais
évoquer c'est la longévité c'est ce qui
est la continuité ce qui me paraît
important c'est une continuité
européenne voilà ce que je ce soir c'est
ce que veut retenir ensuite on fera la
part des choses
mais ce soir moi je voudrais vraiment
parler uniquement et d'une image s'il
faut retenir une image je retiendrai
celle de du chancelier kohl et du
président me taire leurs dents à verdun
là il n'y a pas de complexité
il ya une authenticité une verra si
alors juste et au fond pour moi c'est
aujourd'hui ne pas parler d'autre chose
justement à propos de l'europe monsieur
jacques delors merci d'avoir répondu à
notre invitation dans un septennat
d'hommes politiques de chefs d'état dans
deux septennats pour ce qui concerne
monsieur françois mitterrand dit
finalement il n'y a pas beaucoup de très
grandes décisions pour ce qui concerne
monsieur mitterrand qu'elles ont été
notamment en matière européenne les
grandes décisions
je pense tout d'abord qu'il faut
rappeler qu'il était déjà là en 1948 au
fameux congrès de la haye présidée par
winston churchill et où le cri
d'ensemble était plus jamais la guerre
entre nous elles ayant rencontré
quelques années après j'avais été frappé
par l'impression qu'il gardait de cela
et toute sa vie il a manifesté un idéal
européen
parfois même je suis comme lui donc
pourquoi nous parle confessé au delà du
réalisme avec une vision d'avenir
je crois que si je devais je choisir un
prêt j'en prendrais qui est peu connu
c'est que l'europe était en pleine
stagnation entre 1980 et 84 à cause des
demandes intransigeante de même thatcher
et il a lui-même nouer les fils des
douze difficulté qui existait il a vu
chaque chef de gouvernement et à
fontainebleau
ils à régler tous les contentieux ce qui
a permis ensuite à une relance de la
construction monsieur mitterrand a vu
beaucoup de choses en amont il a aussi
peut-être manqué un ou deux tournants de
la vie politique internationale comme
par exemple la chute du mur de berlin on
n'a pas eu le sentiment qu'à ce moment
là le père la buick est vraiment pris
conscience tout de suite de l'importance
de l'événement
je crois qu'il ya en a pris conscience
aussi vite que les autres chefs d'états
membres de l'union européenne crois que
là on lui un an lui un temps qu'un faux
procès et d'ailleurs certains ouvrages
qui lui sont consacrés rétablisse la
vérité mais il est évident qu'ils
n'étaient pas dans ma situation
moi en tant que président de la
commission européenne je devais dès le
lendemain rappelé qu'ils étaient dans le
traité de rome un soir quai 17 millions
d'allemands de l'est faisait partie
automatiquement que d'europe bien alors
monsieur joxe monsieur léotard d'abord
peut-être monsieur pierre joxe ce qui
est assez fascinant dans le parcours
politique de monsieur françois vite et
on sait qu'il a combattu la vème
république la constitution de la vème
république et puis qu'ensuite et bien il
s'est coulé dans le moule
fondé par le général oui mais n'avait eu
beaucoup de choses fascinantes et ces
changements c'est transformation par
lucidité et je crois aussi par
patriotisme tout à l'heure madame v en
parlait il était un jeune homme de
droite
une famille conservatrice il a commencé
par être un pétainiste et il a été un
résistant
mon père qui l'a bien connu me disait
mitterrand il a vraiment été pétainiste
comme beaucoup de français d'ailleurs
ensuite il vraiment été résistant c'est
le patriotisme je crois qu'il a fait
comprendre que le pt disputer les 1
heure c'est l abaissement national
c'était le renoncement et il n'était pas
nationaliste était un patriote de même
il appartenait à des gouvernements qui
minait les politiques coloniales
affreuse j'étais enfant par un deuxième
guerre mondiale j'étais étudiant pendant
les guerres coloniales françaises et
bien c'est le patriotisme il a amené à
comprendre que la décolonisation était
inévitable nécessaire
et comme le disait ma naissance passée
dans le camp de ceux qui étaient pour la
décolonisation et je crois qu'à travers
toute l'afrique il en a gardé des
amitiés très longue de même il a été un
anticommuniste il a appartenu à des
gouvernements qui était particulièrement
anticommuniste et c'est lui qui
rassembler les forces de gauche et qui a
comme nous le rappelait tout faire
il ya donc une lucidité un patriotisme
qui la menait toujours à chercher ce qui
était finalement le vrai intérêt de la
france d'un point de vue n'ont pas
encore une fois nationaliste je partage
l'analyse de jacques delors mais d'un
point de vue de ce qu'il est plus
profond dans l'histoire de la france
c'est à dire la lutte pour la liberté
partout dans le monde d'un an vous avez
évoqué votre paix religieuse qui était
un ministre du général
quel est le pas quel parent dont il
n'aimait pas beaucoup mais quels étaient
les halles est qu'elles sont allées
qu'elle était à votre avis les rapports
entre mitterrand et de gaulle c'est un
rapport très très cool éléments attendus
quand il était plus jeune et se sont pas
mis longtemps dû après mais les terrans
était un résistant et il est un de ceux
qui ont su comprendre de quel côté et
est international et il a risqué sa vie
peu de gens savent qu'il a mais leïla
résistance peu de gens savent qu'il est
décoré de la légion d'honneur
à ce titre et donc c'était un homme que
de gaulle et beaucoup de boulistes
estimé françois léotard vous avez été
ministre sous la cohabitation fait
partie de ces jeunes hommes politiques
qui ont été on a eu le sentiment parfois
fascinés même s'il n'était pas de votre
bord par françois mitterrand pourquoi
peut-être il aurait aimé être dans la
situation où je suis où je vais être
c'est à dire de parler avec respect de
quelqu'un qu'on a combattu probablement
aurait-il aimé cette situation j'ai
connu l'homme de culture
pétri de culture j'étais ministre
culture à ce moment là et le chef des
armées et les deux
ces deux hommes là pourtant
contradictoires qui pourraient l'être
étaient des hommes très solide séduit
vraiment très solide et j'ai réussi nous
avons réussi je dis avec simplicité à
faire passer la sphère des grands
travaux
j'étais beaucoup plus proche de lui
qu'on ne l'était autour de moi dans ce
gouvernement
et j'ai partagé avec lui pendant le
période où j'étais ministre de la
défense beaucoup de l'analyse aussi sur
la yougoslavie que ne partageait pas
beaucoup de mes amis et donc c'est très
difficile de parler de quelqu'un qu'on a
combattu mais dont on a partagé quelques
unes des grandes options ce qui est ce
qui est mon cas je ne vous cache pas que
je me sens beaucoup plus proche du
général de gaulle françois mitterrand et
c'est évident si je devais faire
référence à quelqu'un dans le passé mais
ce soir je partage la tristesse de la
france parce que c'était un grand
monsieur
c'était un grand monsieur et comme je me
souviens de beaucoup de conversations
avec lui notamment littéraire qui
dépassait largement le cas des relations
politiques
mais si vous me permettez je me souviens
du dernier conseil des ministres où
savait faire 700 ou 800 x qui rentrait
dans cette pièce et où il nous a fait
une leçon d'histoire formidable et un
nom et s'est tournée vers les grandes
fenêtres qui donnent sur le jardin il a
dit voyez quelqu'un l'eau sera là
bientôt et il était la vie et les fleurs
ya le soleil et et c'est à ça qu'il faut
penser parce que ça ça restera c'était
très beau il nous étions tous très émus
est-ce que vous avez gardé un souvenir
de la dernière conversation peut-être
vous avez eu que j'ai fait il ya deux
semaines je suis allé le voir là où
repose sa dépouille
aujourd'hui je suis allé le voir pour
lui donner le livre que j'avais rédigé
et nous avons eu une longue conversation
sur l'amour et nous en parler
littérature etc je gardais de cette
période a duré presque une heure et
demie je n'arrivais pas à partir j'étais
gêné parce qu'il était fatigué il aimait
ça y est mais perdre du temps que
j'étais pas grand chose pour laisser du
temps au temps et il est mais perd du
temps ils pensaient probablement que
discuter avec cet homme-là donc une fois
qu'ils étaient pas très important mais
ça pouvait le lui servir me servira mois
par lui et je trouve y avait une forme
de générosité dans l'échangé
intellectuel avec lui de très grande
générosité parce qu'il faisait partager
quelque chose est juste un mot sur la
yougoslavie son obsession c'était la
chute de l'empiré austro-hongrois et
donc il re situer à chaque fois
dans l'histoire les crises aujourd'hui
mais ça c'est une très grande force pour
un homme politique
je ne vous cache pas que j'ai beaucoup
appris pourquoi bien messieurs avec de
l'or françois léotard pierre joxe on va
vous retrouver dans quelques instants
dans la france en direct nous auront
tout loisir de revenir sur la vie
politique la vie tout court de monsieur
françois mitterrand mais ce journal leur
s'avance nous allons continuer à évoquer
un certain nombre de points importants
de la vie politique de monsieur françois
mitterrand lorsque mêlant de la
république qui est arrivé au pouvoir en
1980 on s'est aperçu très vite que
malgré son âge il n'était plus très
jeune il avait un rapport particulier
avec la jeunesse vous souvenez de ces
formules sur la tontonmania sur le côté
branché parfois un petit peu excessif
voyons ensemble quelles étaient ses
rapports privilégiés car entretenu un
bon moment le président de la république
avec les jeunes français florent ce
qu'il a
de la mort de mitterrand
durand
pour moi
les manceaux n'attend pas non
non pas moi
je suis je suis pas chez la juve nerfs
je préfère habiter en plus vraiment au
monde
j'ai la haine quoi est faite à ça me
touche parce que je suis relativement
jeune
même si j'ai pas été toujours
entièrement d'accord avec lui
il a quand même vous vernet 14 ans et
gouverner plus de la moitié de ma vie
donc oui c'est pas seulement une
génération qui s'est retenu en un homme
sinon je sais pas une génération qui
s'est reconnu dans l'est pour certaines
valeurs
k crew en
nouveau socialisme les valeurs de cette
génération là ça plaît aux ti racisme
solidarité amitié elle souhaite racisme
on devenait le fleuron en juin 1984 à la
concorde la génération mitterrand était
déjà en marche avec les jeunes partout
françois mitterrand avait le contact je
suis pas un mec bien moi je n'aurais
génération de mutants mais pas seulement
c'est vrai qu'il n'a pas versé mais
qu'il a été le président pour les
agenais sont que c'est vrai qu'il a en
fait on avait l'impression que c'était
le président du coup quand on est petit
qu'on me voit comme ça on va on apprend
que finalement les hommes changent
alors une canne mais pas jusqu'à
maintenant
jean qui est plus noble mais en même
temps
vrai que les derniers
les dernières informations par entre
autres avec un disque est du cas qu'on a
sur lui la rencontre pour accéder à l
âge adulte façon il faut tuer le père
donc voilà le père avait cumulé morts et
maintenant peut-être la génération
mitterrand à pouvoir accéder à la fin du
temps alors je vous parlais des endroits
que les hommes qui parviennent de
pouvoir rendre ses lèvres on a parlé de
la rue de bièvre partons maintenant vers
la che dans les landes là où l'ancien
chef de l'état avait une maison depuis
de très nombreuses années maintenant
ce matin notre reporter gilles mariné a
rencontré là bas l'un des compagnons de
captivité pendant la guerre de monsieur
françois mitterrand prévenus par la
famille mitterrand jean et ginette
minier viennent d'apprendre la nouvelle
jean est celui qui fit évadés françois
mitterrand alors qu'ensemble ils étaient
prisonniers de guerre en allemagne
proches voisins le couple avait passé le
réveillon du nouvel an en sa compagnie à
latché le lendemain en fin d'après-midi
gens munis a vu son compagnon d'armes
pour la dernière fois c'était dans la
chambre bibliothèque de la résidence le
lieu préféré de l'ancien président je
suis donc allé frapper à sa porte je
suis entré ils étaient allongés et était
très très fatiguée allongé dans son lit
et je me suis approché de lui jeu et met
la main sur le front et je vais demander
françois est ce que tu vas de la fierté
souffre et il m'a répondu non non mais
je sais que mon concert se généralise et
puis fermer les yeux à peine en europe
donc il était déjà très très très
fatiguée et vous assemblez à ce
moment-là qu'il n'était plus déjà avec
vous avec le monde amiens mais ils
n'étaient encore si vous voulez mais je
senti qu'il abandonnait son regard
montrer qu'ils n'espéraient plus rien
c'est tout c'est tout ce que je puis
dire sur sur ce moment qui a tout de
même été extrêmement pénibles pour nous
quelques heures après cette ultime
entrevue françois mitterrand quitté la
che pour ne plus y revenir
aujourd'hui la résidence landaise
protégée par un imposant dispositif
policier était déserte
vous en doutez depuis la disparition de
monsieur françois mitterrand les
télégrammes de condoléances affluent du
monde entier
celui dont nous allons parler maintenant
et celui de monsieur gorbatchev qui
avait d'ailleurs été reçus dans cette
maison de l'atce par le président
françois mitterrand monsieur gorbatchev
enregistré aujourd'hui à moscou par
notre correspondant l'écoutent des
hommes comme lui s'en vont mais s'ils
restent non seulement dans l'histoire
mais dans la mémoire de ceux qui les ont
connus et pour moi françois mitterrand
restera pour toujours dans ma mémoire
comme un homme politique de stature
internationale mais allah au calibre
comme un intellectuel cas qu'un homme de
qui tu choques oui tour et des mains et
mme au crac
bien qu'il ait pu être oculaire masqué
mais personne n'a jamais dit que la
démocratie devait être synonyme de voler
ce concept 5oo mâts socialiste il ne
cachait pas ses convictions
non décidément cette date un président
digne français qui exprimait et
défendait les intérêts de son punch et
il avait représenté la france dans le
monde entier et devant toutes les
nations at c'est comme ça que je m'en
souviendrai n'apporte toujours à
l'instant même celle président américain
monsieur bill clinton qui vient de
déclarer monsieur mitterrand était un
grand homme d'état qui a beaucoup fait
pour la paix dans le monde
parmi les hommes politiques qui avaient
une relation je crois d'amitié avec le
président françois mitterrand le
chancelier allemand helmut kohl ensemble
ils avaient fait progresser l'idée
européenne il avait
marcher ensemble n'a même pas écoutons
la réaction de monsieur helmut kohl
françois mitterrand était un grand
européen un grand patriote français et
un ami fidèle de notre pays il a eu
l'expérience de la deuxième guerre
mondiale de la résistance de la lutte
contre hitler et le nazisme et il a
nourri de l'expérience de sa propre vie
la conviction que la paix et la liberté
de nos peuples le peuple français comme
le peuple allemand
les garanties que dans le cadre de
l'europe il fut l'un des grands
architectes de la réconciliation et de
l'amitié germano française
moi même je perds un ami cher un homme
un bon camarade il m'a soutenu dans les
moments difficiles par ses conseillers
c'était un homme d'une grande culture
qui face à la communauté internationale
a toujours envisagé les grands problèmes
mondiaux non seulement dans l'immédiat
mais dans une vision qui englobait les
causes fondamentales du scotia
sa mort est une grande perte pour nous
tous autres chefs de gouvernement qui
entretenait avec monsieur mitterrand des
relations beaucoup plus que
professionnelle monsieur perez le
premier ministre israélien il lui disait
aussi des choses très directement
souvenez vous qu'à propos d'israël
monsieur françois mitterrand s'était
rendu à jérusalem pour dire là bas bien
avant que ça se réalise que les
palestiniens avaient le droit à une
patrie écoutons monsieur perez pour nom
et la terre et amis d israël
il connaît l'histoire gip plus que les
autres leaders
il gardait toujours ainsi matt est vrai
pour l'état juif
ils soutiennent la négociation pacifique
entre le valletais et nous mêmes il
était signaux qu'un joueur du vrai et le
râle ben israel va faire les
négociations chercher la solution est
finalement trouvé une solution
il lui a dit qu'il considère que le
conflit entre les arabes et nous mêmes
et parmi les plus compliqués problème
dans nos temps ci à cause de notre
époque réaction maintenant de monsieur
yasser arafat qui se trouve aujourd'hui
en voyage à paris yasser arafat que le
président françois mitterrand avait
rencontré à une époque où n'était pas
encore bien vu sur le plan international
de trop fréquentes et le leader
palestinien monsieur arafat s'écrase
parce qu'il ya beaucoup de souvenirs à
la clé
mais je n'oublie jamais que au moment
même à ça où il était lycéen
pierre brasseur beaucoup de chefs
d'états de me rencontrer
la cause des conditions dans lesquelles
nos passions il avait le courage
pourquoi venir de me rencontrer we will
be you tube et de soutenir notre cause
juste
au diable je laisserai la cause du
peuple palestinien et je regrette qu'il
a quitté ce monde offrir et que nous
l'avons perdue alors qu'il ne voit les
résultats de nos élections
dernière réaction internationale
maintenant celle du président du conseil
italien monsieur d'igny enregistrés par
notre correspondant à rome
alain de chalvron musini c'était un
homme qui avait une grande vision des
problèmes de notre société et comme l'a
été souligné
c'était un homme qui avait une vision
européenne est très clair qu'il a portée
en avant avec détermination malgré les
différences qu'il pouvait avoir
même au sein de la france nous en nous
c'est une grande perte pour la france
mais je la veux cette ouverture europe
c'est un grand vide la ville seine et
garonne est tout le temps en italie
également également nous sommes très
très triste
c'est vrai puisque nous en parlons à
l'instant que le président françois
mitterrand aimait beaucoup à voyager
dans deux pays particulièrement l'egypte
où il a passé ses dernières vacances
donald l il avait l'habitude d'y aller
et puis on vient d'en parler instant
l'italie monsieur françois mitterrand
était un véritable amoureux notamment de
venir lorsque françois mitterrand arrivé
en italie
il savait qu'il était un peu chez lui
bien sûr il était le plus souvent
assaillis par les obligations
protocolaires ou politique mais il
mettait même à profit ces moments là
pour faire un peu de tourisme se faire
expliquer une tapisserie ou
histoire d'une statue comme ici à
florence tous les prétextes en tout cas
étaient bons pour défier les services de
sécurité pour une promenade sur la place
royale de naplouse dans le petit village
sicilien de taormine pas toujours facile
de se promener quand on est président de
la république française ultra connue en
italie et apprécier metteur en effet été
très populaire il ya eu aussi deux des
contrariétés des hostilités parce que la
priorité était remarquable mais en
général il a été populaire il était
doublé surtout dans l'opinion de gauche
de centre gauche dans l'opinion de laïcs
je me rappelle il y avait des bals
publics dans la rue en italie la
première fois que murray a gagné c'était
comme une victoire de la gauche
italienne
au delà de la politique mitterrand adoré
l'italie et sa culture
venise où il se rendait aussi souvent
possible encore depuis son départ de
l'élysée venise où il avait dit ont
acheté un pied-à-terre et florence qui
le fascine et à aimer beaucoup les télés
pour ceux qui ont envoyé 10 il venait
souvent réglés il n'a pas aimé d'apc que
j'ai c'est la classe politique est à
dire les amuse italie les pays les
grandes villes historiques dennis clowe
a surtout peu rance
rien d'étonnant dès lors que les
italiens lui aussi rendu un peu de cet
amour qu'il avait pour l'italie
avant de poursuivre cette édition
spéciale je me dois de même de vous
relater les quelques informations en
bref qui forment le reste de l'actualité
avec d'abord un terrible accident
d'avion dans le centre de kinshasa au
zaïre
un cargo antonov qui venait de décoller
de l'aéroport de kinshasa s'est abattu
sur le centre de la ville sur un marché
précisément il y à au moins 250 morts
l'équipage russe de l'appareil qui n'a
pas été blessé et qui souffre que de
blessures légères est aux mains de la
police il a été arrêté visiblement il
s'agit d'un décollage manqué l'avion
s'est abattu en plein centre ville de
kinshasa
l'autre affaire concerne la france les
traminots aux marseillais ont enfin
trouvé un accord avec la mairie et leur
entreprise sic avec le conseil général
on voit ici monsieur gaudin signer cet
accord
les modalités financières du règlement
du conflit
on était donc définitivement réglé
aujourd'hui après plus de 32 jours de
grève
et puis encore le journal info matin
info matin est paru pour la dernière
fois aujourd'hui avec ce titre on revoir
coïncidence avec la mort de monsieur
françois mitterrand info matin pour
l'instant aucune solution n'a été
trouvée
le journal ne paraîtra plus à partir de
demain
revenons donc à l'information qui nous
intéresse à savoir la disparition de
monsieur françois mitterrand nous avons
parcouru les lieux que le président
lui-même avait rendu célèbre parmi ces
lieux il ya bien sûr château chinon
château chinon c'est la deuxième vince
et la ville d'adoption c'est la ville
politique de monsieur françois
mitterrand c'est là qu'il s'est fait
élire pratiquement sans interruption
depuis 1946 député sénateur président du
conseil général
il avait là bas ses habitudes patrice
randle on ne fait pas de politique sans
fief château chinon était celui de
françois mitterrand et pour les
habitants de la ville l'humeur aussi est
aujourd'hui entre fatalisme et tristesse
on connaît pas les gens savaient rien
mais quand on les connaît sa passion
c'est toujours bizarre de voir des
images historiques mourir parce que on a
toujours l'impression qu'il sera plus
mortelle alors ça c'est ça fait bizarre
quoi et puis il a fait beaucoup pour le
moment et pour château chinon qui
s'enorgueillit d'abriter le musée du
septennat ou les sculptures de niki de
saint phalle face à la mairie
une mairie conquise en 59 et abandonné
en 80 un successeur qui apprend
aujourd'hui que françois mitterrand
reposera à jardin
ah oui bien sûr je regrette je regrette
tout à fait parce que j'étais un peu les
garder tout à fait chez nous c'était
pour les gens de château chinon pouvant
aller j'aurais cueillir j'essaie
vraiment regrets oui nous adultes ni
regrets aux enfants la candeur chacun
ici conserve une image une anecdote
chine à l'hôtel du vieux morvan où
françois mitterrand a pris son élection
en 1981 il reste cette chambre il reste
cette vue sur une région qu'il
chérissait et une plaine quelque chose
d'impalpable le souvenir retour
maintenant avenue le play dans le 7e
arrondissement de paris là où est mort
ce matin aux alentours de 8h30 monsieur
françois mitterrand vous voyez devant la
porte d'entrée de l'immeuble les gerbes
de fleurs de rose bien entendu qui sont
déposés par les parisiens anonymes et
les personnalités qui viennent rendre un
dernier hommage à l'ancien chef de
l'état mort ce matin à l'âge de 79 ans
retour sur cette journée justement
devant cet immeuble de l'avenue frédéric
le play à paris avec un reportage de
michaël darmon
on connaissait à françois mitterrand la
rue de bièvre au bord de la seine
ce matin de nombreux parisiens ont
découvert la venue le play près du champ
de mars
c'est ici que françois mitterrand cet
état il était 8h30
des voisins ont compris tout de suite on
est du dernier quart vente et qu'on a eu
les barrières du matin je n'ai aperçu
plusieurs fois oui puisque j'ai un chien
donc il fallait il faisait des
promenades régulièrement
après fatigué il y avait un long moment
qu'il était hissé des stations ainsi
fait il était régulier dans ses
promenades personnalités politiques
parents amis tout le monde se présente
au domicile de l'ancien président ceux
qui ne peuvent entrer dans l'immeuble
viennent simplement déposer leurs
témoignages à la maison c'est parti
comme ça c est emprunté 50 francs ma
concierge pour prendre le métro les
castings et tout ce qu'il veut venir ça
a été très avec lui en restera là il y
avait 14 mai liberté c'est satisfaire
obtenir g14 libère nous affranchit de
l'autre côté de l'immeuble
on laisse une signature quelques mots en
échange une photo il est décrit en a
certainement un moule à survivre ou pas
fait personnel en fait mitterrand
n'était pas être mon bord mais je
considère que c'est un grand français et
je le respecte
c'est très triste chagrin c'est un petit
peu comme comme si mon père par terre
parce que je trouvais qu'il avait dit
des choses tellement importante qui sera
appelée remplaçable quand même il me
touchait beaucoup un titre de journal
transformé en message personnel un
groupe de photographes silencieux des
anonymes mais aussi certains avaient
pris l'habitude d'accompagner l'ancien
président dans ses promenades le
souvenir que je garderai demi mais
quelques phrases que j'ai changé a pas
longtemps avec lui montrer ses photos
vous êtes trouvé pas mal tiens bon
souvenir mais déjà toute la journée le
fleuriste ou proches est devenu un
passage obligé
il n'y a pas eu de rejet ça fait rien je
vais quand même prendre une blanche dans
la nuit et mélancolique avenue du play
devant la demeure de françois mitterrand
certains comprennent qu'une page de leur
vie s'est tournée fait 32 ans françois
mitterrand c'est la moitié de mes vous
et c'était beaucoup d'espoir tout n'a
pas été tenus mais une bonne partie je
pense que plus ça va aller plus on va se
rendre compte de l'important simples
citoyens aux responsables politiques
la discrète à vous mais le play dernier
lieu parisien de françois mitterrand ne
désemplit toujours pas quelle image
choisir dans la multitude d'imagés de
photos qui ont jalonné la vie de
monsieur françois mitterrand pour
terminer cette édition spéciale
nous avons choisi un document original à
l'occasion du centième anniversaire de
la naissance du cinématographe par les
frères lumière
nous avions confié une caméra tels que
les frères lumière l'avait utilisé pour
qu'ils filment quelque chose dans la rue
et régis wargnier le cinéaste avait lui
choisi
c'était l'été dernier comme figurant
comme acteur
monsieur françois mitterrand donc qu'il
l'avait choisi de le filmer vous voyez
là dans les jardins des tuileries
monsieur françois mitterrand qui s'était
volontiers prêtés à ce tournage voici la
caméra des frères lumière et nous allons
voir monsieur françois mitterrand dont
dans laxe de cette caméra faire quelques
pas qui d'une certaine façon symbolise
la vie d'un homme politique qui a
traversé son siècle
le voici françois mitterrand né le 26
octobre 1926 est décédé donc ce matin à
8h30 à paris dans sa résidence
parisienne françois mitterrand qui sera
inhumé jeudi prochain dans l'intimité à
jarnac sa ville de naissance dans les
charentes
je voudrais remercier l'ensemble des
journalistes de la rédaction de france 2
ainsi que les reporters d'image
l'ensemble des techniciens est également
qui depuis ce matin 10h30 assure sans
interruption la diffusion des
différentes émissions à la mémoire de
monsieur françois mitterrand dans
quelques instants nous allons nous
retrouver en compagnie de bruno masure
et nos invités pour une france en direct
spécialement consacrée bien entendu à la
vie politique et à la vie tout court de
monsieur françois mitterrand des
documents des invités donc pendant plus
de deux heures
mais dès demain matin également je vous
le signale deux heures d'information
non-stop entre 6h30 et 8h30 avec des
reportages revue de presse invités et
liaison avec nos correspondants à
l'étranger
voilà ce journal est terminée nous nous
retrouvons dans quelques instants
compagnie de bruno masure pour une
france en direct spécial consacré à la
disparition de l'ancien président n'a
public monsieur françois mitterrand
bonsoir à tout de suite